hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
how the devil are you
Marvel spider-man on ps4 releases
September the 7th worldwide in fact it's
only sixty six thousand two hundred and
forty minutes from the moment I'm saying
this not that I'm counting the time of
course thanks to reveals from Sony from
Game Informer and the events at Comic
Con 2018 we now know seven suits that
are confirmed to be in the game which
alternate costumes are you hoping for
please let me know in the comments and
upvote your favorites for me I want the
cosmic spider-man aka Captain universe
or maybe cyborg spider-man before I get
sidetracked yet again let's have a look
at all the confirmed suits complete with
their special powers and origins in the
Spidey verse the first thing I want you
to be aware of are the pre-order bonuses
that have confused a few people in
Marvel's spider-man these are the
insanely techy iron spider suit the
spider punk costume complete with the
guitar and the all new velocity suit
don't feel that you need to pre-order to
pick these up they are completely
available to all players but must be
unlocked in game for most gamers
unlocking the suit will be a great deal
of fun and dedication but if you don't
have the time and you don't want the
rigmarole of unlocking three suits then
the pre-order bonus has these unlocked
right away it's essentially early access
anyway let's break them down I'm
starting with the spider punk suit
inspired by the punk rock movement in
the 1970s which stood against Authority
and gave young people at the time a way
to express themselves offensive t-shirts
leather jean jackets studs and spikes
everywhere in game the spider punk suit
will come with a guitar which has an
area of effect attack when Spidey pumps
out a guitar if the enemies around him
will be stunned by the noise allowing
spider-man to get the upper hand in the
fight in the comic books
punk-rock Spidey is a relatively new
version of the webslinger first
appearing in earth 138 under the mask is
not Peter Parker it's Hobart Brown who
was once the Prowler in the amazing
spider-man but this is an
alternate-dimension Hobie takes on
Norman Osborn who became president and
his army of cops with their venom
powered armor Hobie used punk rock music
to find like-minded people
and by connecting all the guitar amps
together they were able to create a
sonic wave which weakened the officers
and allowed Spidy to get close enough to
the president to use his guitar in
another way I think this will be the
suit I mostly use in Marvel spider-man
roll on September the 7th next up is the
iron spider suit which is inspired by
Marvel's Avengers infinity war in which
Tony Stark designs and builds a suit for
Peter to use in the impending battle
against Thanos what is truly
jaw-dropping here is the amount of
communication between Sony insomniac
Marvel games and Marvel Studios to make
this suit possible collaboration on this
level is rarely seen so be sure to enjoy
the Aisne Spider suit in the Avengers
film we haven't seen many of the
abilities the suit has to offer probably
because there are so many superheroes
and villains to share the screen with
Peter Parker but we can go back to the
comic books to see the powers it
possesses in issue 5 29 of The Amazing
Spider Man Tony Stark finishes building
this new skin for spider-man who has
aligned himself with Stark during the
Civil War storyline the first thing
you'll notice is the red and gold but
that's only the beginning the iron
spider has webbing attached to allow
Peter to glide through the air the suit
is bullet resistant like you'd expect
and there's even an inbuilt police
scanner
realistically all of those abilities
could find their way into spider-man on
ps4 if that's not enough the suit also
has protection against toxins kind of
like a hazmat suit and best of all extra
spider legs realistically it would be a
heck of a lot of work for insomniac to
add legs to general free-roaming in the
game but I believe those extra legs will
be there as part of an attack or maybe a
fall animation allowing Peter to land
safely it really would be a shame not to
see those extra limbs but don't hold
your breath on that one next up is the
velocity suit revealed at comic-con 2018
this costume is completely new and
designed for the game by acclaimed comic
book and film costume designer ad
Granoff his work is simply sublime as a
name implies the velocity suit will
enable us to move around the city with
more speed the suit looks damn good with
metallic paneling and the best bit is
seen when the lights are low glowing
spider-man insignias oh and his eyes too
so damn cool
so those were the pre-order instant
unlocks but that's only the beginning
let's quickly talk about the classic
suit this is the suit we'll be starting
the game with and as you'd expect it's a
nod to the og spider-man suit from the
amazing adult fantasy comic book first
seen in issue 7 back in 1961 by issue 15
spider-man was on the front cover the
ability this suit offers is a damage
boost after hitting a combo to signify
this Spidey's hands will glow it has
been said that a four times damage
multiplayer can be built up in combat as
it supposedly spider-man's first fully
formed suit it won't have tech
advantages like the iron spider or
themed attacks like the spider punk suit
it's here to be minimalist clean
functional and a nod to his humble
beginnings we won't be in that suit for
long though as the advanced suit will
quickly become our base model a lot of
people refer to it as the white spider
suit so I'll use both names the advanced
suit is the main costume we've seen in
almost all coverage around spider-man
ps4's reveal and it's a completely
original design by insomniac the games
developers they broke down the suit in
an interview over on Game Informer but
the main talking point to take from the
suit are the materials used to create it
the typical boot Spidey once wore have
been replaced with running shoes
different materials are used to allow
for additional mobility whereas the red
parts seem to offer more support and
padding this shows how Peters design
skills have developed over the years
this leads on perfectly to another suit
we've only seen for a split second on
Peter's phone did you catch it
yeah the homemade suit in spider-man
homecoming we went back in their history
books to relive the homemade suit it's
one of the most iconic costumes aside
from the classic or the black suit
versions of Spidey
everything is super cheap and customized
from Starke clothing but check out those
eyes top tier costume design as a bonus
to the homemade suit did you notice the
poster behind Peter it's a wrestling
advertisement from shortly after Peter
discovered his abilities soon after that
he saw a sign offering $100 to any
person that could stay in the ring with
crusher Hogan when he showed up in this
terrible outfit most people laughed but
as the masked marvel he won the cash the
character model in the ps4 version looks
very different but it looks complete so
I fully expect to see the luchador
inspired outfit
in spider-man on ps4 and finally the
spider-man noir suit has been confirmed
by a Game Informer's coverage but
without any details therefore the
ability is still unknown we can take a
guess at it by looking back at noir
suits history written back in 2009 but
set in the 1930s an alternative
spider-verse introduced this design
which swapped Peters wall-climbing
ability with guns
yes spider-man carries guns in this
universe the story is set during the
Great Depression era where Peter Parker
stumbles across this godlike spider
which gives him his new spider abilities
in this universe spider-man is once
again tracking down Norman Osborn who
killed his Uncle Ben in this world it's
uncertain what ability this costume
could have in the ps4 version of
spider-man but we could surmise that a
stealth ability to remain unseen could
tie into the all-black attire or maybe
we'll see those gun marksmanship skills
peter has gained in this alternative
universe time will tell I suppose so
there we have it 7 confirmed
alternative suits for Spidey to wear in
Marvel spider-man on the ps4 what other
alternative costumes are you hoping for
spider-man 2099 the new enforcer so is
pretty cool maybe the spider-man
unlimited version the list is endless
I'm Adam from Playstation grenade thanks
for watching I'll be back very soon with
more Marvel's spider-man information
it's been an absolute pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]